this is the Aedes aegypti mosquito it's
the main mosquito that carries Zika
developing a Zika vaccine could take a
decade so right now officials only tool
is to control mosquitoes the Zika virus
was first identified in Uganda in 1947
and caused relatively mild flu-like
symptoms in May of last year
Zika appeared in Brazil since then
Brazil has seen an alarming increase in
babies born with abnormally small heads
a birth defect called microcephaly in
just 10 months Zika spread from Brazil
to Central America Mexico and the
Caribbean and it's expected to reach
almost every country of the Americas
several cases have already been reported
in the u.s. the Aedes is the same
mosquito that transmits dengue and
chikungunya it transmits Zika by biting
someone who has the virus and then
biting another human the virus then
moves to new areas where mosquitoes
hitch a ride on travellers or cargo or
more often when patients infected at one
place go to a new territory and are
bitten by mosquitoes there there's also
some evidence that it can spread through
sexual content but it's the possible
transmission for mother to fetus through
the placental barrier that has health
officials alarmed some countries are
telling women to put off getting
pregnant for months or even years
only about one in five people infected
show symptoms for those who do get sick
the illness usually isn't severe lasts
about a week however researchers are
also investigating a connection to Keyon
Barea syndrome a nerve disorder that can
cause paralysis what will it take to
stop see other than traditional methods
to control the sceetos one strategy
that's currently being tested is
genetically modified folks the Brazilian
government has approved the expansion of
a pilot program to release male
mosquitoes that have been modified so
that when they breathe wild females the
offspring die early studies have shown
high success rates but opponents fear
unknown consequences the technology is
also in its infancy as more people
travel there's a higher chance of
mosquito-borne diseases like Zika is
spreading to new places ultimately
authorities will need better weapons
against bugs